sono qui per parlarvi della passione
siamo tutti qui per parlarvi della
passione Ma che cos'è la passione io non
so darvi una definizione della passione
è così tante cose è il vento che fa
andare avanti la barca ma bisogna
saperlo gestire bene Questo vento perché
vi può far andare Fuori Rotta la
passione è ciò che vi fa svegliare al
mattino ogni volta e vi fa andare avanti
per la strada
nonostante tutti i sacrifici necessari
per andare avanti
non vi so dire quando è nata la mia
passione è era un impulso naturale era
come se lo avessi dentro di me da tutta
la vita era come se io dovessi fare
questo
immaginate questa scena è il 2008 siamo
in una villetta in periferia e sera è
tardi e in cucina Si sentono delle voci
degli adulti che parlano della loro
giornata e sistemano le stoviglie e
invece in questa cameretta
addobbata come da bambina cioè il letto
dell'Ikea la cartella con tutti i libri
per terra e un tappeto pieno di giochi
di LEGO di Barbie buttatele a terra ma
c'è questa ragazzina questa piccola
Serena che ho dato di 6 anni che non li
guarda i giochi no sta davanti allo
specchio e ripete il loop questa scena
che si ricorda da un film appena visto
con i suoi genitori
E allora piange ride enfatizza tutti i
gesti a tutti gli effetti recita senza
sapere quello che stava facendo Lo so
che sembra un po' da pazzi psicopatici e
raccontare questa storia perché è una
ragazzina da sola che piange e ride da
sola in camera però era ciò che mi
faceva sentire viva era ciò che mi
faceva sentire libera
io non so perché mi è nata questa cosa
ma una cosa lo so Per certa che la
passione non la scegli
è una cosa che veramente ti nasce dentro
e tu hai due opzioni seguirla e lavorare
costantemente per seguire questa
passione o assecondare e assecondarla
oppure metterla da parte sminuirla che
per carità la cosa più facile del mondo
ma Che spreco è
Io vi so dire mi ricordo come fosse ieri
il giorno in cui decisi di studiare di
studiare Questo era una lezione di
musical
tenuta da Christian Ginepro e di una
brevissima conversazione con Cristian
che si avvicinò a me e mi disse Queste
due parole che possono sembrare così
semplici così banali
ma mi aprirono un mondo diedero un nome
a quello che sentivo dentro lui si
avvicinò a me mi disse Tu sei nata per
questo
il fuoco dentro di me è esploso e da
quel momento io cambiai accademie corsi
qualsiasi cosa trovassi corsi di
recitazione cinematografica di teatro
eccitazione cinematografica in inglese
qualsiasi cosa perché ero pronta a
crescere e a fare di tutto per seguire
questa strada che io mi sentivo dentro
di me che era la mia strada per carità
non è facile non è facile ma io ho avuto
questa grandissima fortuna di avere i
miei genitori e la mia famiglia al mio
fianco
che in realtà si sono portati anche fin
troppo al limite addirittura Mio padre è
arrivato a mettersi delle parrucche
improponibili e calzamaglie per poter
fare Musical con me Mi dispiace papà ma
grazie
[Applauso]
Questa è una cosa fondamentale Non
spegnere mai il fuoco della passione
delle altre persone
può essere può sembrare facile cercare
di spegnere il fuoco delle altre persone
per poterle
superare per poter andare avanti
superarle ma non è così perché ti aiuta
anche a te a stare accanto alle altre
persone
per carità quando decidi imperterrita di
seguire la strada della tua passione ci
sono fin troppi ostacoli
che vengono ovunque sia dentro di noi
che ostacoli effettivi oggettivi
Però se hai la fede in te stesso nel
continuare la tua storia
vi assicuro che l'universo
sarà il vostro fianco Dopo i miei
numerosi anni di studi
a 16 anni l'universo dalla mia parte e
decise di farmi arrivare questo provino
per il ruolo di Gemma Doria nella serie
mare fuori
feci questo provino e non vi mento Feci
una cosa che non sarebbe mai da fare
cioè ogni giorno mi svegliavo e
aspettavo disperatamente la risposta di
questo provino che non bisogna fare
perché sennò ti distruggi dentro se non
fai altro che aspettare una risposta
però Lo feci e mesi passarono mesi e
mesi e dopo sei mesi arriva questa
risposta mi volevano vedere a Napoli
Allora io e mia mamma ha preso il primo
aereo e ci ritroviamo a Napoli a fare il
provino con il regista
non mi ricordo nulla di quel provino ero
emozionatissima L'unica cosa che io mi
ricordo è il momento in cui sono uscita
dalla stanza del provino in lacrime
disperata tanto che mia mamma quando mi
ha visto era preoccupatissima corse
verso di me mi Abbracciami disse No
tesoro Non ti preoccupare non farti
abbattere dai no non ti preoccupare
prenderai il prossimo la direttrice del
casting che era accanto a me la guardò
come fosse pazza e le disse signora no
Ma l'hanno presa
e si vede il sorriso di mia mamma che
scoppiò e poi però si rese conto che in
realtà non era così positiva Come cosa
perché mi avrebbe dovuto accompagnare a
Napoli per sei mesi essendo io minorenne
quindi Scusa mamma se ti ho dovuto far
fare questa cosa Però grazie
[Applauso]
e quindi il giorno del mio
diciassettesimo compleanno io mi trovai
a Napoli su un set
cosa che avevo idealizzato da così tanti
anni ma poi mi resi conto che non mi ero
mai preparato effettivamente ad
affrontarlo mi ritrovai in una
situazione che era così lontana dalla
mia in un mondo che così Era così
lontano dal mio lontano dalla mia scuola
che ancora Frequentavo
dai miei amici da quello che al tempo
era il mio ragazzo e dalla mia famiglia
e io ogni giorno sul set lo passavo tra
una scena e l'altra a studiare in
camerino Ogni giorno una cosa diversa un
giorno matematica l'altro giorno cinesi
inglese eccetera e quel poco tempo che
mi rimaneva lo passavo al telefono a
piangere con le mie amiche con il mio
ragazzo che non comprendevano questo
fatto che io li dovessi mettere da parte
per seguire la mia strada
nei primi due anni della della serie
Napoli che è una città che alla fine mi
ha dato così tanto L'ho vissuta
malissimo L'ho vissuta perché provavo
così tante emozioni la gioia di stare su
un set ma anche mi sentivo distrutta
dentro perché stavo perdendo
continuazione amici e relazioni passate
e poi persa com'ero mi ritrovai a
provare solamente le emozioni di Gemma
il mio personaggio un personaggio che
effettivamente
ha subito troppo ha subito violenze ha
subito un tentato omicidio
e quindi io mi ritrovavo tornavo a casa
e mi toglievo con lo struccante il
trucco i lividi che mi mettevano sul
viso ma quando me li toglievo io li
sentivo ancora perché mi ero bloccata
dentro Gemma
vi assicuro che in realtà ho pensato
numerose volte di mollare perché per me
che era una ragazzina di 17 anni mi
sembrava così difficile
Ma poi invece capì
capì una cosa fondamentale quando mi
vedi in televisione per la prima volta e
mi arrivarono i primi messaggi
di risposta a quello che avevo portato
capì quanto era fondamentale
la mia passione è la passione in effetti
è responsabilità è responsabilità perché
mi ha dato la possibilità di trasmettere
delle emozioni alle persone la cosa più
bella che esista al mondo provare delle
emozioni ti fa sentire vivo ma non solo
le emozioni mi ha dato la possibilità
pure di far arrivare un messaggio un
messaggio contro la violenza
quanti ragazzi e ragazze mi scrivono
ragazze mi scrivono che magari con
vedendo Gemma sullo schermo si sono rese
conto della violenza che stavano vivendo
nella loro relazione e cosa che mi ha
stupito molto di più Invece i ragazzi
che mi scrivevano che dopo aver visto la
storia di Gemma in televisione si sono
resi conto degli errori che stavano
facendo
è una responsabilità enorme lo so però è
un onore
grazie grazie
la cosa che amo così tanto è il poter
lasciare un segno anche se microscopico
nella vita delle persone
è veramente un onore per me essere qui
perché circondata da tutti queste
persone che hanno il fuoco dentro della
passione come me e a voi che mi
ascoltate vi voglio solo dire questa
cosa scoprite Che cosa vi fa battere il
vostro cuore sempre più forte e
perseguitelo con tutta la forza che
avete senza aver paura dei No delle
degli errori perché non si impara
dal vincere Si impara dagli errori non
si impara dalle vittorie
non abbiate paura di correre rischi
veramente la passione è così bella ci
permette di vivere tutta la nostra
bellissima vita al meglio
Io vi ringrazio per avermi ascoltata
Grazie
[Applauso]